banking on those two advanced points
they are definitely far advanced yeah
and they tie down one of black's rooks
so uh the material count black is
actually ahead black has a rook for
white's bishop and porn white's bishop
not great right now but it's all about
those two white pawns and
duda he's trying to hope that maybe he
can just stop the white rook getting
active i need to be flashy which can be
very very very
annoying because you can't move
basically so it's it's really sad that
one remaining black pawn on the queen
side on the left side of the board now
is about to drop that white bishop is
hitting it there's no way to defend it
yeah you have to take it and then dude
is crying yeah
three seconds two seconds he's gotta
give up for the bishop okay he goes
active but this is not going to end well
it's not going to work
he's trying for some checkmates and
magnus doesn't even allow it look at
that such control yeah like he shuts the
door on any entry for the black rook and
now black really has to get rid of that
white bishop the white bishop's about to
take a pawn and win the game and judah
doesn't even continue he doesn't try to
save it he resigns